the bottom line is that start Trek does
it wrong how dare you you take that back
right now take that back right now take
it
back Star Trek is completely correct in
the Star Trek universe Star Trek when it
comes to warp speed and time dilation is
not correct when it comes to our
understanding of the theory of
relativity the problem is you see the
high warp Maneuvers are faster than the
speed of light yes and if an object
moves through our Curren space at faster
than the speed of light then it can
violate causality and so that whole
aspect of Relativity and so forth is
necessary to make sure that the arrow of
time and the way that we uh know
understand history and the changing of
the universe stays okay the causes occur
before events yes yes when you have a
circumstance like warp speed right that
goes out the window